on espn  and it was i'm still amazed by just how  beautiful this building is and the  latest technology as well  and great for the fans now you really  get to experience it you know  now that we're allowed back down there  oh dear lord i guess his light's okay  katie  the recovery is there yes  ron james  watch tristan thompson his former  teammate  this guy  found something and i want to get a lot  of it  yeah the kings have gone small here  putting harrison barnes at the four and  it really has allowed the lakers to go  out on a little bit of a run this is a  big lakers team and they are taking  advantage of having the size advantage  over this smaller lineup that luke  walton has out on the floor and terence  davis checking in right now you've got  davion mitchell i mean harrison